Now that we've covered querying
with our content provider,
it's time to start inserting data.
Let's take a look at the incomplete
content provider insert function
we provided in the source code.
As you can see, this function takes
advantage of the URI matcher code.
But it only requires the base URIs.
That's because inserts
are fundamentally simpler.
We simply want to make sure that the
right record ends up in the right table.
The data that is contained in
the other URI, such as location and
date, will actually be in the content
values used in the insert.
Note that if we wanted to,
we could support all of the URIs here.
But it makes the implementation of the
insert function far more complicated.
When we insert into the database.
We wanted to notify every
content observer that might have
data modified by our insert.
It turns out that cursors register
themselves as notify for descendents.
Which means that notifying the route
URI will also notify all descendents
of the URI, ones that contain
additional path information.
Just like with calling
our content providers.
We can use a content resolver
to notify our content observer.
As you can see, the root URI for
each table in sunshine
just contains the context scope,
the authority, and the table name.
In the case presented,
the content URI that contains a date.
Is a descendant of the plain
weather content URI.
If we notify based on anything
other than the root URI.
Then a cursor listening on the root
URI will not get notified of a change
that would certainly impact it.
So we have to be very
careful when doing that.
Let's go back to the source code.
For weather,
we just passed the perimeters that came
into the content provider into
the data base insert call.
We should throw an exception
if the insert fails.
The only trick here is to make
sure we return the correct value.
Which is a URI.
Fortunately we made a function
to build these URIs
which contained the weather
path followed by an ID.
If we were being complete in our content
provider implementation, we should also
implement these URI types in the
contract URI matcher and query function.
But the beautiful thing about
implementing a content provider,
especially if it's only being
used by your application,
is it you only need to
implement the features you use.
So we just set the return URI by
using the build weather URI function.